I don't get it man like it's it's
there's there's no way to actually know
or predict how things turn out in the
real world yeah exactly and so many
people base their view on what they
expect to happen on movies and stuff so
like they'll look at a pandemic and
they'll say but this is nothing like I
assumed it would be and then like I
assumed the movies I saw right exactly
the picture of what I've got in my head
and then what ends up happening is it's
confusion and and known as any idea
what's happening and everyone assumes
it's gonna be really really you know cut
and dry the government comes in a guy in
a suit says this is it the pandemic is
here when in reality it's like nobody
knows nobody knows that this could
disappear tomorrow
it gets essentially worse it'd be the
worst thing we've ever seen yeah and and
the challenge is a lot of you know one
thing that people never see when they
when they base their realities off
fiction movies books is like the media's
role in what is acceptable so so let me
tell you something
YouTube would not allow me to talk about
this so on my main channel can't talk
about because so so like they've got my
main channel under scrutiny that if I
cross the line so here's what happened I
was talking about Trump okay and
passively mentioned that thing in China
they suppress the entire video just
because that hard suppression and I was
like what and so I like reached out to
my people at YouTube and they're like oh
we're sorry we'll remove that that's
that one's okay because you didn't talk
about it and I'm thinking to myself I
was like dude how how insane is it that
our political sphere is being heavily
impacted by this yeah and you told me
straight up if I talk about it you're
gonna basically take my video down it's
because the powers that be think the
American public are stupid no I don't
breathe oh that's what it is I think
they're I think they're stupid and I
think I think they were like well we
don't want to make the ever times angry
so if anyone talks about it just shut
their video down yeah it's like so then
what happens is I have no choice but to
omit all of that information otherwise
the video won't exist at all
and that's that's that's the conundrum I
have so I'm on my second channel on here
I'll talk about whatever I want yeah but
on that because they're not scrutinizing
these channels mmm like if we talk about
it right now they're they don't they
don't even know this channel exists it's
a brand new show
yeah the other channel the other
channels are blacklisted for real so on
my second channel until we are now I
think we'll be fine
no yeah yeah but on my main channel it
was actually one of the challenges today
was I wanted to talk about how they
might cancel the debate over coronavirus
CNN is pulling out the audience they're
getting ready the audience I mean
couldn't do it I think that's amazing
anyway I think there shouldn't be an
audience they can use debate on I heard
I heard rumors Bloomberg paid off half
the audience and like every single time
I watched I was just so annoyed every
time yeah yeah it's like I know let him
talk I'm not I noted I'm not wait so you
can clap the best part was when Bernie
was like your supporters are all
billionaires Bloomberg and they booed
him that's like wait what it's yeah
because he attacked Bloomberg I know I
know like but but hold on if it's true
that Bloomberg paid off the audience how
stupid are you because like why is the
audience Bernie was confused when people
start booing him for that yeah it's like
wait wait who's cheering for the
billionaires Yeah right apparently these
people are no but but anyway I got I got
I got a call from Google today Oh Google
called Google called me I mean it yep
Google Google called me what up good and
they said that starting next week you
and only a few other people are clear to
talk about coronavirus oh good feel kind
of special I mean but I was like I was
kind of like I'm like listen I use
certified news outlets like this nature
thing cuz oh this is crazy
the engineered bat virus stares debate
this is certified by news guard look at
this like it's green across the board as
like a legitimate thing and I'm not
saying it's related any of this but it's
certainly making you know people are
freaking out like there's a legit news
source but anyway yeah they told me that
they're there the initial thing that
they were dealing with with coronavirus
was they like whenever there's a
short-term high-impact event that causes
loss of life yeah advertisers
specifically say like we don't want to
be involved in that and we'll opt out
right okay so YouTube then says these
videos are no good but because this is
our life for the foreseeable future what
I was basically told by the Google
people was we've basically resigned
ourselves to accept that if we say
demonetised corner
virus there will literally be no
monetized videos yeah cuz like literally
but they were like yeah because III was
cancelled right South by Southwest so if
you're a musician you're like hey guys
why don't you know that we're gonna be
canceling everybody monetized it's like
well dude I'm talking to my fans yeah I
came and say the word it's like when I
said that thing in China even that hit
boom suppression so what does that mean
like that you get substantially less
views okay like like they don't show it
yep keeping it under wraps so it depends
on the level of suppression for this
video I'm predicting like or I'm
projecting around like 33% suppression
it means that however the algorithm
works they don't show it to people yeah
and they can't see it on my videos or
whatever I have no idea what if they
search for it'll pop up no really yeah
yeah and I've I've had suppression that
was like 90% reduction I don't know how
it works I have no idea
all I know is you can see it based on
your trends and patterns in the day and
everything there's a predictable pattern
of view counts like you it's it's it's I
know if it's a if it's a Tuesday I'm
probably getting around a certain amount
of views yeah I know if it's a Sunday
it's a little lower or whatever and this
day was like what the yeah I leap and so
I reached out to them they fixed it but
now they're saying basically they're
they're letting in only a few people to
talk about this and I'm gonna be one of
them and I'm like that's kind of dumb
but whatever what can I say
but thanks I'm right yeah I guess okay I
can talk about it I'm not gonna I well
here's here's the thing I don't plan on
making like dedicated main channel
videos like coronavirus because we do it
all the time here and I made a channel
but at least now I can say coronavirus I
can say the word use there's one word I
can't say right now hmm I can't even I
can't even sing I can't even tell you
what it's about like this stream will
shut off
really that's YouTube welcome to future
have you told me it before I think so we
talked about it probably I think I know
you're done it's a guy yeah can't say
isn't I know I call him Voldemort oh
yeah I think kidding yeah you told me
this day for those that are watching if
I save all the more one guy's name this
stream will get shut off instantly
well like in 10 seconds someone's
watching us so
but hit the button dude it's it's it's
so insane I was I've yelled it Lex I I
know I've known a lot people at Google
for a long time and I I know people who
work in different news divisions they
actually invite me up but it's not
YouTube but it's like YouTube peripheral
okay the YouTube people I wouldn't call
like my friends but I have friends who
have worked at Google and stuff like
that and I've yelled at them like you
are suppressing information and you are
causing serious damage to our our
democratic institutions violations of
freedom of press and you are
manipulating your power as a tech
monopoly over the space and they're like
we can't do anything about it because
here's what happens this is the craziest
thing to me Susan what's-her-face the
CEO of YouTube okay has published today
you are now allowed to talk about
coronavirus oh oh everyone know she said
we are updating our rules and they'll be
rolling out soon okay but they're
effective immediately there will be
people who are now allowed to speak
about coronavirus okay and I saw that
now is like excellent does that mean I
can now be approved to talk next week
next week how does that make sense that
the CEO is gonna be like we're okay with
these people to talk about chronal virus
and then I'm told yeah but next week
that is weird
doesn't the CEO have the ability to just
like boom yeah do it no well in the
grand is too big and earlier in a week
everyone's gonna be quarantined yeah at
least they'll be unable to watch your
videos yeah yeah yeah yes yes so from a
business point of view YouTube views are
gonna go up people are gonna be panicked
wondering what the hell's going on yeah
yeah there's our one H word I think
we're allowed to say hell more often
than that so yeah but but they do start
reducing and there's a spring of D
monetization some network did a study
and found if you swear mm-hmm it's like
a 70% reduction in ad revenue you know I
said you know the what the hello over
there like I said matter well I said
that in front of a teacher like Oh like
I saw the teacher now I just like walked
past him like what the hello teacher and
I actually got detention for it oh and
you were a nice butt and I thought it
was like a cool teacher I didn't
that teacher was in a bad mood that day
the teacher looked at me and was like
did you just say that to me and I'm like
not a word I was joking with you what I
was like a 14 year old you know I
thought it was funny I all right engine
let's let's let's grab some super chats
and then because we're only gonna be
going an hour today so we can see what
Donald Trump has to say about everything
oh yeah it's important and you all
should watch this too so if you're
listening here's here's some at nine
o'clock Eastern Time president Trump is
gonna be speaking I don't care if you
like the guy or not we should be hearing
what he has to say there's gonna be
important thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you